[Music]
hey folks welcome to the
7314th Darkhorse live stream podcast it
is Saturday here it's actually the 169th
podcast is that correct it is
um nonetheless either way I'm still Dr
Brett Weinstein you were Dr Heather Hein
and we are going to chat about some of
Chad is no longer a term that we are
ever going to use we are going to
discuss some of the uh the circumstances
of the era and um events of the day and
uh all those sorts of things
all right I tripped myself up I said
chat my blood pressure left about four
times and uh I'm back I feel I'm I'm
calm again so
there's that all right
um we're gonna we have a lot to talk
about we're going to be relatively uh
rapid here today uh we are not going to
be doing a q a today and we are not
going to be back here next week so you
will see us next two weeks from now
um but we do have uh a number of
interesting things to talk about today
Twitter and
sports bras wow yeah
um yeah okay not the natural triumvirate
you would expect no no the big three I
guess three four I mean depending on how
you count sports bras
why would you count them as two except
for the obvious reason and it can't be
that
okay
um we
aren't digressing because this is what
we're doing this is what we do this is
we digress for a living I hope I hope
that's not true uh okay so uh join us
now and then two weeks from now uh and
and we will have stories to tell I think
yeah by then uh so this week on Natural
Selections which is where I write weekly
on my sub stack I wrote about
um my father who died 10 years ago this
week and I'm gonna show you a tiny bit
of that once we start talking in the
main part of the podcast but I encourage
you to go there and uh truly appreciate
subscribers they're both free and and
paying subscribers we have at our store
which I still failed to put the URL in
here Zach and I'm trying to get your
attention the URL for the store
ispodcast.org thank you Store Dot
darkhorsepodcast
dot org dot org we have pins for
instance star course pins uh which you
can put on yourself and use as a bad
signal to others they are you can also
use them to deflate Chinese spy balloons
I feel like you'd have to get really
really close at which point there might
be a better approach to dealing with
Chinese Bible no that was totally
implied that you would have to get
really close but okay
thank you
okay I'm derailing conversations right
and left so that's about uh par for the
course yes uh we are supported by you
when you uh subscribe to Natural
Selections when you read our book
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century
uh and when you subscribe to our YouTube
channel our Odyssey channels are um our
Dark Horse podcast clubs channels on
both YouTube and odyssey like share what
we do uh with other people right now I
saw uh today's clip that just got put
out was our discussion of um
of the madness
um that happened to Kelly G
in uh in
I'm not forgetting it was both Australia
and New Zealand where the the madness
happened we talked about that a couple
weeks ago so there's a clip out now on
that and sometimes those clips are
easier to share for people
um you can also join our patreons where
in two weeks we will be having our
monthly private q a right now you can
ask questions at mine and
um and also join our Discord server
where people are having fantastic
conversations virtual happy hours
karaoke All That
and of course we have sponsors whom we
choose carefully and whom we really
appreciate we start with the uh
oh no if you're gonna start reading my
notes to myself this is going to become
a very confusing podcast space the vast
majority of our audience as far as we
can tell
um don't watch they only listen and so
that just dead air will be utterly
meaningless to to those the vast
majority of the audience
um
you were writing something I looked over
as I as I sometimes do and I I had two
simultaneous
reactions both of which stock me short
they were
that's legible
when did that start and secondly
but it's not English
so what does it mean I can read that and
can't interpret it oh wow that's not the
usual order of things so I'm sure we
will hear about whatever that means um
that I think you've written yourself an
acronym reminder of some sort here so
it's just a series of letters so without
um without the language Associated yeah
hopefully it's enough that when we get
there I will still remember what they
mean which is not always the case but
sure sure but at least it's legible I
can tell you what the letters are you
can struggle with them I will ask yeah
amazing congratulations on the Newfound
legibility well thank you you are
welcome okay our sponsors this week our
house of macadamia's MD hearing aid and
Vivo Barefoot so without further Ado let
us launch into those House of macadamias
is our first sponsor this week tree nuts
are delicious and nutritious they're
generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates unlike what various food
pyramids and government agencies might
have led you to believe high fat low
carb foods are increasingly understood
to be both satiating and good for you
but each species of nut is different and
for many of us macadamias are the best
they take a very long time to grow
however and because they are both rare
and highly sought after they have the
dubious dissension of being the world's
most expensive nut between the taste and
the health benefits they're worth it
they have even fewer carbohydrates than
most other nuts for instance half of
what cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose they're also uniquely rich
in omega-7s including especially
palmettoic acid and unsaturated fat that
has been linked to Natural collagen
production fat loss and heart health
I almost read about health and heart
loss which would not be useful but I can
assure you that there are no cases at
least in the scientific literature to
date of macadamia nuts causing that
instead
recorded with the alien abduction heart
loss it's not a common medical condition
no it really is because especially in
you know prompted by a dietary intake
yes that's uh that'd be a hell of a diet
it would uh and how's the Macadamia is
its intent on making this amazing food
accessible to everyone they have
partnered with more than 90 of farmers
in Africa and now make one-of-a-kind
vegan Ketone paleo snacks these include
their dark chocolate dip macadamias and
a delicious assortment of bars made with
45 macadamia nuts and flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut but
our favorite product of theirs is the
simple salted macadamias made with
namibian sea salt they're amazing we
love them and think that you will too
and House of macadamias also makes a
delicious macadamia nut oil which is 100
cold-pressed rich in monounsaturated
fatty acids and has a higher smoke point
than Olive Oil so is well suited to high
heat cooking and baking it's also
delicious our house of academias Highly
recommends House of macadamias
macadamias for all of your academic
needs go to www.house of macadamias.com
and use code Darkhorse for a 20 discount
on every order plus Dark Horse listeners
will receive a complimentary four ounce
bag of macadamias when they order three
or more boxes of any Macadamia product
once again that's
www.houseofmacademias.com use code
Darkhorse for 20 off every order you
won't be sorry
our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost
helping bring audio Clarity and capacity
to people who might not otherwise be
able to afford it while we don't have
need for hearing aids ourselves we have
a friend who does and we asked her to
assess this product carefully and
honestly she did in her testimonial is
at the end of the sad MD hearing aid was
founded by an ENT surgeon who made it
his mission to develop a quality hearing
aid that anyone could afford he kept the
price Low by simplifying the product
removing several rarely needed
components and he made a product that
aims to fit so well no one will know
you're wearing it other features include
rechargeable batteries that last up to
30 hours water resistance and up to
three feet of water and their volt plus
model and you don't need a prescription
to get one
MD hearing aid is cut out the middleman
so you buy your hearing aid directly
from the source for audiologists and
licensed hearing Specialists are
available seven days a week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from that friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and this is what
she said quote with my particular type
of hearing loss a deep male voice and a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand I wore the MD
hearing aid to have a conversation with
a deep voice man a room with a lot of
white noise the MD hearing aid passed
the test as my conversation partner's
voice was clear and understandable at a
price point of well under a thousand
dollars I was amazed at how effective
they are
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
and MD hearing aid recently cut their
price in half so if you want MD hearing
aids smallest hearing aid yet go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids cost
just 149.99 plus Dark Horse listeners
receive a free extra charging case a
hundred dollar value so head to MD
hearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids for only
149.99
all right our final sponsor this week is
Vivo barefoot shoes made for feet
everybody should try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
feet but not vivos vivos are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them are we sure they all have feet
actually you know in this era we might
want to check but I believe we have seen
no reason to suspect they don't because
they certainly there are enough people
in the company who have feet know how to
use them that they design a hell of a
great shoe that we know very good all
right so
all those caveats have now been taken
care of I feel somewhat relieved
uh all right and word is spreading we
have been asked by strangers if the
shoes we are wearing are as good as they
have heard yep they are they really
really are here at Dark Horse we love
these shoes they are Beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo
barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
Barefoot is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it go to
vivobarefoot.com and use the code
Darkhorse 15 to get an exclusive offer
15 off additionally all new customers
get 100 day free trial so you can see if
you love them as much as we do that's
Vivo
[Music]
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the core
code Darkhorse 15 at checkout
all right
we have uh three broad topics today
would you like to start or should I
why don't you start
okay
um
Instagram influencer
trans woman
Dylan Mulvaney um
I think we have mentioned here before
and I have written about on my substack
in Natural Selections a little bit as
just a sort of a sidebar uh is you came
to prominence uh with
his
365 or girls of dayhood I think is what
it was called no
really not
days of girlhood I think is I think is
what the the sort of
project was called the movie will be
called girls of day which is a pretty
good I don't know what it means but you
know I really feel like I should just
give up
I'm not going to be a clear day it's not
going to be an easy day
um
and that's on me
so uh has had
the amazingly acronymed ffs facial
feminization surgery
and uh says that he's on Cross X
hormones
um although some have suggested that you
know why is there no shape change in his
body and why is there still five o'clock
shadow and all of this stuff and there's
been no other surgery other than the ffs
facial feminization surgery which was
which happened just before
365 days of girlhood and and you know
this was someone who was already in his
20s and is is a very skilled Entertainer
actually an incredibly skilled
Entertainer and if you go back to before
um he began his days of girlhood thing
uh you have him trying out being like a
safari tour leader on Instagram and uh
you know he looks fabulous and I don't
know that he knows anything about
animals at all but um you know he's he's
and he's a singer and a dancer
um although to that point the most
recent the reason that we're talking
about him right now would suggest that
he's never done anything athletic in his
life but
um
he's extraordinarily polarizing because
the world has decided the the half of
the world it seems it seems like half
the world although I really still can't
believe that half of the world actually
looks at this
um well twink you know he's a he's a
very thin very slim attractive
slight gay man
um who's dressing up in akuta mall and
uh and sort of making cultural choices
that look traditionally feminine
and half of the weird world seems to be
going like you go girl like you're a
woman now and he's not he's just not
including invitation to the White House
on the basis of his bravery yeah
so
um
been getting a lot of sponsorships from
various organizations uh Bud Light
but light is sponsoring him and he shows
up in a bubble bath and this just
outraged the the Bud Light drinking part
of the western world and when that
happened I thought and and then
afterwards he put out a Instagram video
in like a jeweled thing drinking Bud
Light claiming not to know what March
Madness stood for and I watched that and
thought man he's good he's a really good
Troll he's really good and again not
untalented like and actually talented
talented guy
but then after the Bud Light Fiasco
kerfuffle you know lots of people
getting irate about it
um
Nike
put him in a sports bra
and is using him to advertise
Sports Pros
and I
you know there's been a lot this
happened I don't know a couple few days
ago and there's been a lot of Hugh and
Cry of course and you know the point
largely is it doesn't have breasts no
reason for a bra there right
but I think it's it's even worse than
that to use your framing right yeah it's
even worse than that which is
um dude doesn't have sports
right like bras
can be a fashion choice right for for
many women not doing
um
harder heavy or bouncy work especially
if they're small breasted a bra may be a
choice
um that is culturally expected that
makes them feel better about how they
look but it really it can be primarily
about fashion
especially if you're small breasted
especially if you're not engaging in
in a lot of athletic activity but a
sports bra
is specifically something that was
created
to help women not damage their breast
tissue when they are for instance
running and so I did
I just I just did a Google Scholar
search on the term
sports bras biomechanical analysis
and uh so if you're not aware of Google
Scholar Google Scholar is um it's not as
good as some of the search engines the
academic indexing search engines that
are behind pay walls that you usually
have to be an academic to find but it's
it's it's quite good uh and here
actually you can just show my screen so
sports bras biomechanical analysis
without any I didn't use any Boolean
operators I wasn't trying to be specific
in any way
um you know there's like 20 over 22 000
results wow right right that's so and I
don't know I didn't I didn't go down
into you know five thousand ten thousand
I don't know what happens down there
right but there's there's a lot of
people writing about what is it that
sports bras should be doing could be
doing are doing how could they be better
what actually is the support that's
needed and
um even if you divide those results by
those that refer to the left side and
those that defer to the right side it's
still a huge number of studies
or whatever they are exactly so it was
just one okay and I just I I
went into a few of them and here's just
one this is published in the journal
ergonomics in 2021
it's got four authors it's called how
the characteristics of sports bras
affect their performance
uh and uh the you know it's
it's a decent piece of research right
the the final sentence of the abstract
is encapsulation style padded cups nylon
adjustable underband and high neck drop
accounted for 37.1 percent of breast
movement reduction variants findings
facilitate high performance sports bar
development and informed consumer choice
okay so you know we we have people in
this case who understand that sports
bras are an item that shows up to solve
a particular problem can I have my
screen back here for a second
um and there you know there are some
papers that are
um
in that same search that reveals more
than twenty two thousand um a little
sillier
um this one is only silly because
um the authors are clearly not native
English language speakers so I'm just
going to read the beginning of this
abstract uh which was a conference
proceeding published as a conference
proceeding in 2009 it's called studies
of sports bra based on biomorphic
analyzes of females breasts
um and you can see the authors appear to
be Chinese
um sports bars are specifically designed
to offer appropriate amount of support
and protection for breasts during
moderate to intense physical activities
so far so good they are the most
important instruments for athletes both
from the excising satisfaction point and
comfortable aspect it's well proved that
the more rigorous the exercises that
athletes take the serious the breasts
injuries could be caused without the
assistance of outside support especially
for the plump ones
there it is so that's just that's
amusing but like still
the English isn't right and if I were to
try to write something in Chinese it
would be far far worse so I'm not
attacking these guys I don't even know
if they're guys I'm just saying that you
know the research on the biomechanical
advantages and aspects of sports bras is
are just being done throughout the world
all right especially the plump ones
especially the plump ones
um a couple points uh one that abstract
will stand as a kind of Time Capsule
what uh you know
international science looked like before
GPT right because of course GPT could
rewrite that abstract and you'd never
know right you'd never know you'd never
know but you'd lose out on especially
the plump one especially the right
exactly that's
it really needs to be there it drives
the point home it does but uh the other
thing is look sports bra isn't actually
kind of an interesting category because
in some ways bras uh I mean
I don't know but I'm assuming that bras
are never having worn even one even half
of one but never having been so inspired
never once I can say that we've not
talked about this but I know it to be
true but in any case the point is bras
presumably originate at least heavily
biased in the direction of augmenting
this native advertisement of lift right
highlighting yes shaping right all of
that
um and it is the liberation of women
that causes the need for a bra that is
optimized around something else which is
the capacity of women to do uh vigorous
things in which bouncing breasts are not
a good thing right so anyway the whole
idea that these things are the opposite
of an ornament these are something that
you do to take something an ornament
that natural selection has stuck women
with and in some ways hobbled them right
and to I don't see you tracking a big
tail around do I no exactly right no
I've always wondered if nice rack was a
reference to Antlers I don't know I
think it must be it's very clever if so
but but it does have that analogy in any
case there's something interesting about
the idea that sports bras are themselves
about de-ordinamintation and increasing
capacity and yet here we find ourselves
in a place where through some uh I think
think new level of incoherence we have a
person who doesn't need this thing
because he wasn't stuck with this
ornament who is now becoming an iconic
okay but we'll get back there okay
actually to exactly the point that you
just made though I have I have a section
here from Runner's World okay from a
from an article published in 2017 which
you can show my screen here A Brief
History of the sports bra so this is not
this is not a piece of science this is
just a review
um again published in 2017 40 years ago
an ordinary Runner invented what she
couldn't find in stores what happened
since then is a story of women
supporting women and just scroll down
and find this one paragraph here almost
without exception
again written in writer's World in 2017
almost for that exception the women are
the first running boom were small
breasted because they had to be even the
famous Reiner's High couldn't
anesthetize the pain of swirling d-cups
and although jog bras opened the door to
a whole wave of would-be Runners the
stretchy pullovers didn't deliver enough
support for bigger sizes
so this this is this is exactly the
point you were just making and uh
there's a for instance there's a company
Title IX of course Title IX has now
become the you know the the
original 1970s legislation has now
become weaponized yes the Trojan Horse
through which all kinds of nonsense but
originally I I still believe that it did
something very honorable and important
for
um female athletes um especially you
know girls being able to um have access
to uh competitive Sports and
um in that vein uh the company Title IX
which makes basically athletic uh wear
for women
um has a as a remarkable diversity of
and detail about the different kinds of
sports bras for not just what size you
are what level of you know Fitness you
are in what what size your breasts are
but also what is the activity you're
going to be engaging in because if
you're you know it always has great
pictures of of women doing awesome
things you know surfing and bicycling
and you know being outside doing doing
sports uh and you know the fact is that
if you're jogging
um and you have large breasts too you
need different kind of support than if
you are than if you are a serpent or
bicycling right so
all that said and I'm not actually going
to go ahead and show
um
show Dylan Mulvaney doing his little
sports bra dance for Nike
but it's it's ridiculous like he he
looks ridiculous and it's not athletic
and
um yes everyone has already said like
everyone who's commented on this
basically isn't like oh doesn't have
breasts why does he need it but my point
here is this additional one which is
you're not engaging in anything athletic
in any way and you were acting a
caricature you were you you are acting
the part of a character of a woman who
thinks it would be cool to be sporty but
doesn't actually know what that means so
this is this is and you know I have
increasingly been using this word and I
didn't used to see it very many places
but this is misogyny this this is a
belittling and a caricature of what a
woman is to put
a guy in a sports bra and have him do
like fake stretches like kind of
yoga-ish things and suggest that's what
sports bras are for and that's what
women doing athletic activities looks
like so uh the way you ultimately phrase
that I I agree with you it is the
pudding of Dylan Mulvaney in the sports
bra that is the offensive thing here I
still am un effectively what this is is
exactly like a
paper mask being required to prevent
covet right the point is this is about
fail tea do are you going to call this
out really are you going to call this
out implying that you think that's a man
and not a woman because if you think
that that's a man and not a woman then
you know what you are you are a
transphobe right so there is that and
this Corporation wishes to Avail itself
of that little tool because at this
moment it sees that tool as uh advancing
its cause presumably it's
um
fiduciary responsibility to its
shareholders
but from the point of view and I wanted
to ask you about this from the point of
view of Dylan Mulvaney himself
he is clearly trolling us
troubling trolling trouble yeah yes
which I'm not sure is bad in other words
it's very hard to make this point and to
the extent I mean it may be that he's
just found a niche and that he is
exploiting it but it is also possible
that he is making a point you know
increasingly like I he is fascinating
and
I started paying attention I don't know
120 days ago of his
girlhood
and
I was
some combination of well repulsed
honestly you know how dare you
um but if if you will admit that this is
cosplay you know what is it that's
happening here and then the ffs so good
the facial feminization surgery out of
which he emerged you know made up in all
of this and looked really briefly like
okay yes you did have your face sculpted
and your throat sculpted so that you
look a more compelling version of of a
woman-ish no changes to the body at all
he just looks like a slim a slim and not
not ripped in any way
dude but the in these last couple of
weeks these this uh the Bud Light
campaign and the
and the Nike campaign
it's very oh there's like there's five
o'clock shadow visible
and this made me start to wonder like
does he know does is he in on this well
I I know there's no way why why would
you be showing that well because you
know it was perfectly it was perfectly
possible for him to be totally
clean-shaven earlier and presumably he's
been on these cross-sex hormones for
longer now he should be able to be doing
a more compelling job now right but
instead he's just rubbing it in
everyone's faces well but but he's a god
let's let's talk about various
possibilities of what he might be yeah
right imagine that he I mean he's
obviously as you have emphasized from
the beginning a very talented person
right right the role he's playing he's
he's doing a great job and skyrocketing
to Fame in no small part because he is
doing this well right now he could be
doing it well out of pure self-interest
right this could be this is how I become
famous and influential and Rich and it's
working and haha right it could be that
which given the stint as among other
things a fake Safari leader in videos
like he was he was looking for the thing
that would hit right right who's looking
for the thing and he found a thing and
it's not his fault that there's a stupid
Niche right he's found it and he's
figured out how to exploit it well look
my hope would be that he is actually
trying to demonstrate how insane
civilization has gone and that there is
a reveal at the end of this right where
he goes back to being a gay man and uh
he points out how dumb people have been
along the way that would be that would
be amazing it'd be epic that would be
epic yeah and that
would uh sure alienate some of your most
vociferous followers still in Mulvaney
um but that would bring a whole lot of
people into uh into your sphere of
influence who at the moment feel simply
uh attacked and insulted and worse by
these Shenanigans yep and now I don't
want them to do it cynically but if he's
been doing this whole thing as an
elaborate
um
Ploy then the point is oh that would be
a very interesting reveal and yeah it
would shift exactly who Embraces this
you know the quality of people that he
hangs out with would be would jump
instantly right
um but in
interestingly actually like he has now a
somewhat long-standing Feud with Caitlyn
Jenner who's like stop it quit it right
now
Caitlyn Jenner is you know
their own
situation and perhaps kind of confused
and all of that but
Caitlyn Jenner is responding to some of
the things that is happening over in
dilemma of any world going nope nope not
not what you say you are that's not
actually how it works right and Mulvaney
is responding with you know crocodile
tears and and uh and you know girls
seeming anger or something you know the
whole thing is well I mean that's sort
of we talked about this last week
it is time it is a long past time for
people who are struggling with whatever
it is to be trans and the difficulty of
those things earnestly
to join those of us who are alarmed at
trans activism and you know something
masquerading in this space and you know
there are people who do
um uh Buck Angel I've pointed to Blair
white have both been very good on this
issue Caitlyn Jenner has been more of a
mixed bag but she is also you know uh
advocated that uh trans women not be
allowed in women's sports for example so
anyway I don't know yeah she oughta know
exactly but I mean apparently she does
so all all to the good and to the extent
that Dylan Mulvaney turns out to be an
elaborate ruse that reveals the insanity
of all these people and the moral
bankruptcy of Corporations
utilizing transness to sell products to
an audience that's in the middle of
being Bamboozled right all of that would
be beautifully revealed by such a thing
and you can imagine that a little bit of
five o'clock shadow might you know
Telegraph to those who were wondering
you know what is this person that this
is knowing so I could see that yeah but
am I right that you would you would um
you would welcome the Revelation that
this whole thing had been a ruse from
Dylan Mulvaney and that it leaves open
the possibility that uh
um
that this was well intentioned
that it took advantage of I think so
yeah I mean I have to think about all
the all the caveats there but yeah I
think
I think he's done a lot of damage
um
he was for the most part
um exploiting an empty Niche yeah
and you know had been someone looking
for niches you know had been someone
with Talent looking for niches tried one
tried the next tried the next found one
it hit he's there
uh
I do not
like the analysis that goes well I don't
like that the niche exists but given
that it exists I'd be stupid not to take
it uh you know I I understand that that
yeah yeah you know that that can maybe
be the case over in like tax law right
like it's my obligation to use the legal
loopholes that have been left open even
while I think they should your
obligation to to play the game up to the
limit of the law but if I really think
that it's wrong I can also be working to
change the law but it's not it's not
hypocritical to take advantage of the
law as it stands it's an it's in fact it
would be foolish to do anything this is
different that's this is different from
this is different from that yeah I agree
uh so
yes of you know to the extent that there
are two possible truths here and there's
probably a lot of Grace gray area but
the do you think since there are two
possible truths here uh what I welcome
uh the that he
has been trolling us the whole time as
opposed to uh the that he is what he
appears to be or what he believes to be
uh yeah of course okay good yeah
interesting all right well do you have
further you want to go down this road I
mean we could talk about it forever but
we got a couple other big topics to go
so yeah so let me just say in closing uh
a little a b testing here oh good you
remember last week when you sprung that
story sprung that story of uh the uh the
armadillos big hairy armadillos with
their nocturnal erections right I think
maybe hairy penises right and my uh my
sense of like well okay but why I don't
really get why people would study such a
thing I understand that it's studyable
and there's nothing wrong with studying
it but it's hard for me to imagine how
you find yourself there I mean have you
seen the size of their penises no
I haven't but the people who are
studying them have exactly yes
um but anyway the point is all right so
that on the one hand very hard for me to
empathize with the person who finds
themselves focused on this as a topic
sports bras
I have no such difficulty I see why this
is a big field and they're like the fact
that there are over 22 000 uh results
no no that makes perfect sense wait I'm
allowed to study that okay yeah
something like that exactly yeah right
um okay yeah
okay
[Laughter]
done
um I don't have Segways this week at all
really so do you want to go next or do
you want me to go into a totally
different topic next uh I guess I could
do uh what I had planned next all right
so I have been uh away this week I was
in Austin for a conference of political
Independence which was fascinating there
were all sorts of people there as you
might imagine there was a tremendous
amount of conversation about Ai and
where we find ourselves
and that sort of thing and I wanted to
um talk about a couple things one I've
now had a number of conversations with
some folks who are both directly and
indirectly involved in AI work
and I've been talking to them about my
biologist's perspective on what is
unfolding more or less with the
expectation that whether or not my
perspective makes sense or it doesn't
that I would be uh you know probably uh
treated as you know not comprehending
the problem because I'm a biologist and
it would take some time for me to
demonstrate that actually there was a
reason to look at it this way it's not
what happened at all that's cute son
this isn't armadillos anymore
right yeah it's not Kansas and any
armadillos
um so in any case I've had a number of
very interesting conversations and by
and large the folks I have spoken to
have had the sense of Yes actually the
degree to which you understand the
underlying code is of limited value
right it's in the same way that
understanding ion channels doesn't tell
you a whole lot about how the brain
processes information right yes it
doesn't do it without the ion channels
functioning but really the point is
you're dealing layers up or you know
somebody uh I think it might have been
Peter Wang said that uh you know you
could imagine that you should study uh
computer science by you know looking at
solder soldering you know no it doesn't
help you right so anyway the the
biological approach seems to be one that
uh people who are in this area realize
is actually absent from a lot of their
thinking and likely to be highly
relevant so okay that's reassuring
um
and I've been thinking in the context of
this conference where AI
played an uncomfortable role frankly I
was on a couple of different panels and
in both cases the organizers of the
conference saw fit to pose a question to
GPT chat for
um you know and just sort of introduce
it into the conversation as what does
the eighth I think of the topic under
discussion both times I had an allergic
reaction and I left no doubt that I
thought it was a terrible mistake to
engage the AI in this way uncritically
even if everything it said was accurate
right for example imagine that 500 times
in a row it gave you a perfectly
accurate maybe even an insightful answer
and that causes you to trust its answer
and then uh some misalignment issue
takes advantage of the trust it's build
up and poisons the well
you know which which people can do too
like sure people can lose track people
can have a brain glitch people whatever
they can be suddenly deciding to game
you because they've created trust for
the first 500 interactions whatever but
um
but yeah in this case the elephant in
the room is the AI what is the AI I
think oh God right well I'm comfortable
with what is the a I think but it should
be done in the context of a deliberate
experiment in which one does not process
it as just another contributor to the
conversation it is anything but that you
do not know what it is doing or why and
it makes sense to not introduce it into
a conversation in which you've just
asked six people to offer an answer
right that that's a mistake in my
opinion but
uh anyway
um the AI was under discussion by many
people most of them not uh computer
science folks or AI Specialists or
anything like that
and I realized that there was some
missing toolkit that I think is
vital and I re I started doing it with
myself
what I realized was that because of the
way and I'm not saying that we have AGI
but I am saying that I think it's clear
that we are about to if we do not
already
because of the way that that is going to
interact with people's
cognition
anything
that you think you know about the way
people function for example the way a
Collective action problem causes
coordination to break apart to become
unstable as you get towards an objective
anything you think you know about the
way people function you should now treat
with a extreme skepticism
right because an AI could interface with
that in any way it could short-circuit
the breakdown in cooperation it could
cause cooperation to work where you
wouldn't expect it to or it could cause
it to break down before you you would
Intuit that right all all possibilities
are on the table so in any case my sense
and when I told Folks at the conference
was I believe that you should at this
point in history
decide that you officially know nothing
right and then go back and check with
all of the things that you thought you
knew from the prior era and see if there
is reason to think they still hold right
so basically a kind of it's a Cartesian
emergency right Descartes became very
suspicious of things that he couldn't
establish uh himself personally and we
could have a long conversation about
that but never mind at this moment there
is reason we have crossed an event
horizon we are in an era in which Nobody
Knows the rules and if you want to know
something then start with the very first
thing you should know which is that you
know nothing right if you wanna if you
want to be ahead the way to get ahead is
I know nothing and you'll be ahead of
all the people who still think they know
something
um you know then you need to rebuild a
toolkit so that's one thing
second thing is and I don't know what to
do with this but
we have had a conversation on Darkhorse
about what we have called the time
traveling money printer which is my
admittedly clumsy label for the concept
that you can generate the equivalent of
inside information if you know what is
coming down the pike and you can slow
down public awareness of it right so we
think that this almost certainly
happened with respect to covid that it
was circulating in September October at
the Wuhan military games but the public
only became aware of it when it was
revealed in the very last days of 2019
in December
and that that would have allowed people
who had been on the short list who got a
phone call who knew that that there was
about to be a pandemic that was going to
spread around the world it would have
allowed them to position and effectively
print money right they could do a lot of
other things but at the very least if
you know what stocks are likely to go up
and which ones are going to like are
likely to go down you can take a small
pile of money and you can make it into a
huge pile of money and it would be
um shocking given the obvious moral
bankruptcy of the people who would
likely have had that information first
it would be shocking if they didn't do
it and there's evidence to say there's a
weird delay between September October of
2019 and December that's a lot of time
last day of December yeah the last day
of December right
so okay the time traveling money printer
is the equivalent of a time machine
given that time travel apparently
doesn't exist as far as we can tell
right it functions in financially like a
time machine right I mean time travel
doesn't exist so far as we can tell in
the same way that selection can't see
into the future but selection has
figured out a way to see into the future
it's the same like metaphorically true
right that time travel does exist yeah
and selection does see into the future
but it does so via means that we don't
think of as time travel are seeing in
the future right now here's the big
bummer
only one
it's big enough that only one is no
Comfort well I'm sitting down whereas
I'm yes you are excellent um if you put
on a helmet I'd feel even better
um I mean you could fall out of your
chair but
let's just agree I'm gonna take the risk
try it okay
um if you're going to fall onto the dog
she's soft enough
so the question is this
did we really get The Cutting Edge we
know we didn't get the perfectly Cutting
Edge obviously they developed these
things inside of open AI for example and
then reveal them did we get something
like The Cutting Edge do we know exactly
where we are in the development of this
is it occurring to all of us
simultaneously that we've crossed the
event horizon or did some of the folks
who knew that we were going to cross the
Event Horizon
um pull a time traveling money printer
on us and the reason that that's such a
devastating question is Not only would
um you know those have
effectively cheated financially again
yeah but
we don't know where we live in the era
of AI if we're playing with vpt4
and
gpt6 is already in some people's hands
then there's a question about what
current events are being affected by
forces that we are behind and coming to
understand I'm not saying I know this to
have happened I'm not saying I even
think it has happened I'm saying we
would be foolish not to wonder if it has
happened
so
yes that said I'm seeing all sorts of
stuff I don't get
right now that was true throughout coven
um so it may be that we are just living
in an era where the
algorithms the non
um
intelligent algorithms and the change
that is opaque to us in the way they
feed us information is causing people to
derange and behave oddly right or it
could be that there's some degree of AGI
that is swirling the pot in some fashion
that we do not understand
and I wanted to connect this potentially
to something a story that really just
started emerging
I think it's today maybe it's yesterday
um
which is the story of Twitter
blocking sub stack links
I have an example here you have an
example yeah you want to show it yeah so
uh this was yesterday uh maybe the day
before yeah I should say obstructing
sub stack link show my screen
um so this week as always I posted my
sub stack at 8am
and uh and then within a half an hour so
I tweeted about it with a link I wrote
about my father who died again 10 years
ago he didn't die again who again died
10 years ago this week actually he did
die again but that was 10 years ago and
then 11 years ago yes the reverse order
anyway
um
I I reprinted I republished something I
had written in the days after his death
on a website that I created for him and
he and here's a tweet and people people
liked it and people went there but went
and so this went out on Tuesday of this
week and it was engaged with and it was
you know liked and retweeted and all of
that which was possible then
but which apparently is no longer
possible that I am allowed to post
something from my sub stack but no one
now can like or retweet it and more
egregiously when I click on this
well that's good news interesting yeah
okay so um an hour ago when I clicked on
that what we got was a message that said
uh this this link oh boy I screenshotted
it somewhere but I don't know where it
was this link may be unsafe uh use
caution uh and now it's actually
clicking through so that changed in the
last hour
very interesting very positive yeah okay
so let me just give a little bit of
history and I'm not going to be precise
about this I don't think the Precision
matters and
um
to be honest with you there was so much
debate over what exactly the details of
this story what the simple facts were
that it was a little hard to follow but
what happened was
uh Elon Musk apparently made the
decision to
um obstruct the liking and the
traversing of links to substack
the question of why he did that
in by his analysis was that sub stack
had behaved in an aggressive way he said
that they had been
downloading a sounded like code
information from Twitter in some form or
other
in large large quantities in order to
effectively use it to bootstrap their
own Twitter competitor in service of
creating what they're calling notes
now what substack is calling notes which
does appear to be that it is in line to
be present to the world as a competitor
and as an alternative to Twitter yep it
does appear that there is a desire on
substance partis as a business to create
something that would uh compete for the
same users right and one can certainly
imagine you know you and I are not big
business people we've never been big
business people but you can imagine that
you have a property and it has
capabilities and you know allowing
somebody to Simply create a competing
thing especially if they're going to
borrow code or information would be
infuriating and you know to the extent
that it is legal to obstruct their
ability to do this you could imagine the
instinct to do it
on the other hand
musk has been very aggressive and many
of us have
spent considerable political Capital
defending him in light of the fact that
he appeared committed to building a a
platform that was at least in principle
a a free speech
Public Square kind of a place and the
idea that you know the Public Square
will have a corporate brand and it you
know that it doesn't exist across
multiple platforms is obviously
troubling what's more
going after sub stack is troubling
because there are very few properties
out there that are really committed to
free speech right I can name effectively
four big ones all right yep you've got
Twitter
you've got sub stack you've got locals
and you've got Rumble which are now one
thing well they're not a c and odyssey
is in I don't know the details but
smaller Rumble and locals are the same
things why I was lumping that as one yep
I I see they're not the same but in any
case people bought locals and so they
are now you've got a small number of
Rebel platforms that are that constitute
a beachhead where free speech is now
possible again after an era highlighted
in the Twitter files of egregious
meddling by everything from the
Department of Homeland Security uh to
Facebook to all of the other platforms
so that's tremendously important and
it's important I I get that there's a
business angle here but it's important
at a level that uh is
profound for civilization and so
whatever is going on would be great if
it got navigated such that the business
folks could do the business stuff they
need to do without disrupting the
possibility that a year and a half from
now or two years down the road there
will still be a place for free speech to
uh to manifest at least in principle so
very alarming what's more alarming is
that in the battling the so there was an
initial alarm by many of us at what this
blocking of substack links was because
sub stack is such a vital player in
terms of long-form
uh content that runs against the The
Narrative it hands agency back to
writers it allows writers to be
freelance and to actually make a living
without
um without needing to be in the good
graces of an editor or an institution
and Twitter is for for many of us the
way that we distribute our work to
audiences that haven't yet found us
right so
um
it is a
shining beacon in a otherwise quite dark
Sea from the point of view of people
looking for for a long-form place and
Twitter is the obvious with the place
where we exchange very short things
including hey take a look at my sub
stack so
what was most alarming here was that
Elon Musk went after Matt taibi who is
obviously caught in this exact bind he
has been releasing the Twitter files on
Twitter in tweet threads which are to be
honest kind of clumsy because Twitter
was never intended as a journalistic
platform in that way and he has been
exploring the same issues at length on
his sub stack
um and so
there was
um
there was back and forth between
musk and taibi and effectively musk
appeared to burn taibi in public which
is a shocking and disastrous development
from the point of view of those of us
who would like to know what the history
we've just been through was about right
the Twitter files is the best evidence
we have to date of what that was really
about taibi has been
um steadfast and
uh ruthlessly journalistic he is just
suffered a
um what would you call it a character
assassination pseudo interview
uh in which yeah so anyway in other
words you know we've been defending
musk in his creation of a free speech
platform and equally defending taibi as
one of the few shining lights in
journalism and taibi caught straddling
the gap between Twitter and sub stack
should be exactly the case that tells
you actually you have to be very careful
how you navigate whatever business
conflict there is there because the
world of people who matters is using
both of these platforms and so anyway
there's a lot of concern I have I have
talked to many people
um
all most or all of them supporters of
musk in his quest to liberate Twitter
and make it a a place where uh free
speech at least in principle dominates
um and nobody understands why he would
do this it's it's confusing so
hard to know what to make of it I do
worry that it has something to do
but you know may be reversed now right I
mean I've tried it as you've been
talking just tried a few ways in not as
me different accounts and they all see
the links seem to be working now that
I've tried so great if you go to uh
musk's Twitter does he
um say anything about it
oh until it doesn't look like a what's
the top tweet
uh a meme you were arguing with
strangers on Twitter here from nine
hours ago okay so something has changed
unclear why
maybe cooler heads have prevailed that
would be fantastic let me just say in
closing this chunk out that watching sub
stack
and Twitter battling in this way as
somebody who uh exists in this very
tenuous
beachhead with free speech as
um the most important tool at our
disposal yeah yeah it was a little like
um watching somebody meddle with history
where on D-Day you've got the forces on
Omaha Beach shelling the forces on Utah
Beach and D-Day doesn't work if this
happens so it's really important that
those actors can just sit back and be
like cool
go for it right exactly so really I you
know I don't know what unfortunately we
are looking at a world that has been
messed up by the fact that when you have
business in conflict with other values
the other values collapse and we can't
have that happen here the other values
are too important we're really talking
about the future of the West and the
future of the West I I know because musk
has been very clear about this the
future of the West depends on our
ability to discuss these things openly
which depends on having Platforms in
which that's possible so uh
please
um
Let's uh let's put those things out of
the line of fire
indeed
all right that's
you good yep all right um
again we're not good on Segways this
week
nobody's good on a segue everybody looks
like a dork
spelled differently it is yeah you know
that actually I didn't know until
um
a long time after the Segway came and
went and it was supposed to have been
this you know the new mode by which we
all get along Ginger along around Ginger
exactly it's called ginger in advance no
one knew what it was yeah uh and then it
came out and people were like I don't
nah that's a pass
well it took decades to re re-emerge as
the thing it always needed to be and now
it exists but nobody knows because
they've spent so much time laughing at
the Segway on Arrested Development and
elsewhere and the thing now is electric
unicycles and and other yeah other
personal electric vehicles which have
come a long way and believe me the
scooter is not the end-all and be all of
that space electric unicycle strange as
it may look is a fantastically capable
tremendously fun device back before we
started doing these live streams but
when Dark Horse already existed yeah you
were talking about actually spending an
episode or two or eight or something on
electric vehicles and specifically
electric unicycles uh because you and
our two sons
um have become excerpt boy is it just
language it's not working for me today
um expert on them and we have we have a
fleet
oh my God and you know of all sizes and
ranges and capacities and have also had
a couple of other electric vehicles but
it's the electric unicycles that the
three of you have you know you've the
boys have commuted to school and I used
to commute to downtown Portland used to
back when we had an office in downtown
Portland it would be a long commute from
here and we live in an island but yeah
indeed you need to recharge yes and you
might not want to take the five the I5
no definitely not but
um but you should do that like you you
should you should you should talk in
more depth than what we're doing now
which frankly for most people gonna be
like an electric what now electric what
now is exactly it's it's you've probably
seen them it's one wheel with two little
platforms either side
yeah pull up a good one yeah but keep
talking um but anyway it's two pedals
either side and here's the thing okay it
looks weird but it is very similar to
downhill skiing very similar to downhill
skiing except that it's powered so you
can go up all
um and you go fast and don't fall off
but it's um yeah and wear motorcycle
gear because falling off it is not like
a bicycle
there we go
no yeah okay I am reminded though and
Zach probably will not want this to
happen but
um as we were living leaving Olympia uh
which uh would have been when Zach was
13 I think maybe
um he made he produced a video of him
mostly him and his brother on electric
unicycles zipping around the Evergreen
campus and other places in Olympia and
and put it to what was the song you put
it to you got um it was like summer
feels feels like summer by Weezer it was
fantastic and you actually showed it to
the people at the school that you were
trying to get into and I think it's
still up we should we should link it
well that's all right I think it's I
don't know why we wouldn't link it it
was great in fact Weezer liked it that's
right
um yeah anyway um anyway here you have a
guy uh ready to get started on what
looks like in in motion
v11 this is this is one of the first of
the uh electric unicycles with
suspension
um that I am not a big suspension guy on
bicycles but on electric unicycles it
makes a huge positive difference why
because you like your knees
um because when you're riding a single
wheel you know you can hit a bump and it
can launch you uh you know skill on a
bicycle is enough yeah you're like okay
I'm gonna steal my pedals down and I'm
not gonna I don't need the suspension
because I have the suspension built in
but you can't do that as much on one
wheel you can but at one point yeah I
say as someone who's biked a lot
Mountain biked a lot but is yet to try
my hand at these objects these yeah your
hand is uninvolved right
um but uh but anyway they're cool
they're really cool I'm not saying
they're safe but they are cool and
you all of
all of you ride them wear full face
helmets and you do also wear you know
motorcycle jackets and motorcycle gear
and wrist guards wrist guards and shin
guards and you don't push the speed
limit because you can the speed limit of
the vehicle not of the right Road the
speed limit of the vehicle actually uh
if you push it you can
cause a drain on the battery that the
motor cannot sustain
really simply you just fall off the
front if you're going faster than it's
going
yes that's true that's the I don't know
you don't have to install the batteries
let's put it this way there that sounds
terrible there are two meaningful limits
uh when it comes to Electric unicycles
one limit is how
fast the machine is capable of going and
how rapidly it can accelerate and then
there's how fast a smart person would go
and how fast a smart person would allow
themselves to accelerate those are
different limits
so anyway lived lived to Patrick almost
19 year old well that's just the wrong
point it's not that you're saying
anything exactly incorrect but it's
really really simple that you can lean
forward beyond the speed at which it can
keep up to you and you'll just fall off
the front and it'll kind of run you over
and you'll accept the gravity yeah then
it'll drive off well not exactly but no
I don't know I don't know why you need
any of them to say there are multiple
limits or anything it's just that if he
was trying to emphasize that uh a lot of
the dangers can be taken care of by not
being a dope
um not all of them I think the biggest
danger is that it's a black box and
unlike anything with more than one wheel
if it fails you're completely relying on
it does not does not fail safely
actually it's not true there are some
pills yes it will no no no no no no if
you exceed certain limits a
well-designed one like the one you have
on the screen will force you to slow
down and Hop Off rather than fail while
you're riding I'm not gonna argue about
this but I don't think that's the
failure mode I was talking about to my
initial Point there's one two six eight
podcasts in the topic of electric
vehicles and electric unicycles in
particular and one of those podcasts
could be a conversation between you and
one or both of your sons one of them is
now shaking its head and some disgusted
you're um right blockheadedness I think
blockheadedness the word that he just
mouths to me no he didn't actually
all right fair enough I agree it's an
interesting topic I have been meaning to
to do that podcast yeah or podcasts
could be could be all right
um finally today
totally different a totally different
topic
I want to share a few excerpts from
uh this book serious Adverse Events an
uncensored history of AIDS by Celia
Farber uh with a forward by Mark Crispin
Miller this was published in 2006 and it
basically became impossible to find she
also wrote Celia Farber wrote an article
in
oh God now I've forgotten um and I've
closed down acrobat uh I think it was
Harper's it might have been Atlantic I
think it was Harper's
um
coming open for me
um in 2006 as well which is still
available which you which you can find
but uh what has happened now in
um last month is that the excellent
Publishing House Chelsea Green has
republished this book
and I encourage everyone to get it and
to read it I am going to be
um sort of reviewing it and Publishing a
little excerpt on my sub stack this week
on Tuesday on Natural Selections and I
wanted to share a few short excerpts
here today
um
again it is you know it is a it's called
serious Adverse Events by Celia Farber
uh republished by Chelsea Green
uh Publishers and
she walks through the history of AIDS
which those of us who were you know we
were young teenagers as AIDS came on the
scene and my mother had a number of gay
male friends in a couple of different
domains in her life
and so I remember being very
uh very struck by and affected by this
sudden Scourge that was mostly
afflicting gay men in in the United
States so if I may add one bit of color
to that yeah I remember most profoundly
the era where the syndrome had been
recognized it was clear that it was
circulating amongst gay men but there
was no awareness of what might be
causing it and I remember the uh the
searching for a plausible cause in light
of the way that this thing spread across
a population
um that that was a very frightening
error where nobody knew what it was that
was causing it and
um
and they were looking for some
explanation that you know there was an
investigation of like sex toys and
lubricants and things is it some toxin
uh so anyway that was a very uh
remarkable era to to watch science try
to wrap its mind around around this
uh disease yeah and um you know one of
the one of the things in this book is
uh the the proposal by not one not two
but but several scientists some of whom
are Nobel Prize winners like Carrie
mollis uh that the conclusion that was
arrived at Apparently after you know all
of this all of this research and you
know extraordinarily well uh defended
which is that HIV is the single causal
factor in AIDS isn't true
and those scientists who made these
claims were then and to a large degree
remain now unable to to speak about it
and you know lost lost their Labs lost
their graduate students lost their lost
their grants lost their ability to
publish because you were not allowed to
to say this thing and as Carrie Mullis
uh says and I think this is in
I don't have it on my screen here I
think it's something I'm gonna I'm
putting together for my for Natural
Selections uh he says I just started
asking people I said you know I'm I'm
writing about this again he won the
Nobel Prize for the invention of PCR
okay of polymerase Chain Reaction uh
which also then was the tool used for
tests for AIDS and thou tests for kovid
which he did not think was the
appropriate use of PCR separate story
uh he in writing about AIDS
at conferences and and such would
approach people and say okay I'm writing
about this and my you know opening
sentence is what everyone knows right
which is that HIV causes AIDS I just
want to reference
I just want to reference because what
you do in science is you reference
everything that isn't such
long-established common knowledge
that there can be no reference right I
think honestly things like
um mammals are sexually reproducing
species with two and only two Sexes that
is such commonly established knowledge
that there isn't any primary reviewed
literature that says that because we've
known that for so long
but anything that is newly uh newly
discovered even if everyone seems to
believe it or
um that
there was any disagreement about
whatsoever you're supposed to reference
you're supposed to have a citation so
that other scientists and anyone else
who wants to can go in and and basically
um track track the argument back and say
you know I I'm not sure I believe that
or oh interesting let me let me get to
the base of that let me see on what
basis we know that and and go there and
um
Carrie Mullis report reported he is dead
now
um reported that when he was asking this
of people in the 80s and 90s can I just
get the reference on that any reference
there must be lots
uh that no one ever came up with one and
uh that to him and to all scientists
should should be enough to raise
suspicions about on what basis it is
that we have a conclusion that is so
universally agreed upon when it is both
new and there doesn't appear to be a
single piece of research that
establishes that it is true
couple things one when I first heard
that Kerry Mullis was not a Believer HIV
denialist yeah I I misunderstood it I
thought oh this is a chemist under
appreciating the complexity of the
problem there are reasons that you might
have a syndrome that is generally caused
by a virus that is not inherently caused
by a virus because other things can
interrupt the Cascade of physiological
Pathways
Etc
I did not really understand the argument
that he was making I would also point
out it's not just Kerry Mullis it's also
Luke watanier who is uh who actually
discovered HIV exactly and believed it
to be good it wasn't Gallo who took
credit for it and and made the claim and
that HIV uh is the only causal factor in
AIDS although even he backed off from
that briefly
um but it was Luke Montagne it was Luke
Montagne and he is also now dead he was
very old unlike Carrie Mullis who died
recently and was not so old but in any
case Luke Montagne changed his position
even though that was a great personal
expense a it damaged his credibility
probably should not have but damaged his
credibility and B his great achievement
uh was the the contribution of the
discovery of this and so the recognition
that it might not be as important as he
had originally thought uh suggested a
very honorable scientist somebody who
would reverse his position even though
it decreased the importance of his role
in the history of science yes
okay a couple of a couple of shirt oh
wait one more thing I also wanted to
point out why it is that we
should be able to ask anything that is
not common knowledge you know that is so
long-standing that we uh can't find the
original reference that you should just
always be able to have a reference and I
want to point out that the telomere
story which many uh listeners of this
podcast will be familiar with and which
is relevant here there's there's a whole
lot in this book about
um drug safety and Drug safety testing
drug safety testing and there's a whole
lot uh about things like covid that
involves the degradation of tissues
which will accelerate aging so anyway
this is a highly relevant topic but the
obstacle to figuring out that little
puzzle was an erroneous result the
result was what the people who had done
the work said it was but it didn't mean
what they said it was you had to be able
to go back and figure out that they had
all gotten their Mice from a related
Source in order to understand that
actually that Source was polluting our
understanding of uh basically Mouse team
mirrors we thought they were much longer
than they actually are because it was
laboratory mice that had had their
telomeres elongated by a breeding
program that uh selected for long
telomeres so anyway it's a perfect case
where you know there's a two-week period
in which I was trying to figure out why
this
piece of information that everybody
stated casually as if it was just you
know so clearly right that you know it
was it was like Bedrock how could it
possibly not be right and the answer was
oh they all ordered the mice from the
same place right so you have to be able
to trace it back for that kind of Reason
yes yes exactly
so here's a
short excerpt from excuse me
the beginning of the book
uh
page 29. today's scientists are wholly
dependent for their survival upon the
will of a conjoined Financial
megalopolis connecting government
Academia and the biotech and
pharmaceutical Industries again this
book was written in 2006.
if you talk to them they almost all
speak of fear fear of losing their
funding
mine's attuned consciously and
unconsciously to the Roar of the
industry scientists writing grants that
are designed to Feed and Fuel it writing
more and more grants and shorter and
shorter intervals than ever before says
Richard Stroman you have to write a
grant a year almost and you have to
write four to get one if you're any good
I got out just in time everybody who's
still in there says the same thing it's
going to hell in a hand basket before
the biotech boom we never had this
incessant urging to produce something
useful meaning profitable under these
circumstances everybody is caught up in
it grants millions of dollars flowing
into Laboratories careers and stars
being made the only way to be a
successful scientist today is to follow
consensus the academy has become the
technology it invented it's lost its
scientific Edge and replaced it with a
technology that follows the market the
tension between the two is that science
is primarily a generator of surprises
whereas technology is anything but
surprises if you're going to produce
something and put it on the market you
don't want any goddamn surprises you've
got the next quarter to report and you
don't want any bad news it's all about
not the short term now
so that's part of the setup for what we
then see with regard to how the rapid
consensus around these single
retroviral cause of AIDS was arrived at
and also then the treatments the
um
now we know largely not safe and not
effective treatments uh that were pushed
to Market very fast uh things like AZT
and protease inhibitors for AIDS
a couple more short excerpts
again from serious Adverse Events by
Celia fiber
the figures we are always given for H
this is in a chapter called what about
Africa
the figures we are always given for HIV
zero prevalence in Africa are based on
Sample studies taken at a few select
prenatal clinics
I cannot reproduce all of them here
because the figures are like billowing
cloud formations always very big very
round figures always estimates and
always capped with a line like experts
say the real figure could be three times
that high which means that the numbers
are arbitrarily arrived at in the first
place
I once spoke to a unaids official in a
casual setting he was sitting at a bar
and we struck up a conversation
not to insult you I said but the figures
your organization puts out are pure
fiction
pure fiction he confirmed leaning
against the bar of this elbow why then
do you put them out money he said it's
all about fundraising High figures
bringing money
when you get such officials face to face
caught off guard they tend to tell you
the truth in simple language
one more so wait wait wait
so a that brings to mind
Veritas project Veritas and it's a
mechanism for discovering what's going
on by
you know
having somebody go on a date with
somebody and yep yep recording it you
know these people they're not in the
dark about what they're doing they're
just in the dark when they think that
they're on the record and you know it's
unfortunate that one has to get them off
the Record in order
you discover the reality I also wanted
to point out that
consensus science reared its ugly head
again this week where Neil deGrasse
Tyson was being interviewed by Dell big
tree and doubled down on the idea that
it was all about you know that science
is effectively synonymous with the
consensus which is exactly the opposite
of the truth everything in science is
falsifiable
I used to make this point when we are
professors when I was a professor I'd
ask some question and I'm not coming up
with a good question right now it's okay
how many people believe X knowing that
there was this was a question on which
people
um would have an opinion because it
sounded right but it didn't turn out to
be true as far as we understand it right
now
and I get more than half the people in
the class to raise their hands and I'd
say well luckily for us science isn't a
democracy
scientific truth isn't established by
Democratic vote it's not majority rule
that's not how it works
and I don't understand how um
I was able to make that point over and
over and over again to undergraduates
many of whom had you know very little
background at all in scientific thinking
before I met them or you met them and
they got it and Neil deGrasse Tyson
doesn't get it
well I mean I think I don't want to say
it's inexcusable though
I think it probably is yeah but the
problem is that so few people
have intimate contact with actual
science as it takes place right even
people who have formally gotten degrees
in this thing you have to run an
experiment and it has to be properly
structured so that the philosophy of
science is Manifest in the structure of
what you did in the lab or in the field
yeah
yeah and the idea that you can do every
single other thing right right there can
be no way that anybody who walked into
your work could detect that you weren't
behaving scientifically and if you just
screwed up you know the philosophy of
science part if for example you collect
the data not knowing what you were doing
you spotted a pattern in the data and
then you reported that pattern as if you
had had the hypothesis going in right if
that's the only perturbation on normal
science
you it up you didn't do science
you don't have a scientific conclusion
you don't know anything and so the idea
that that something so concrete as
science could be dependent on something
so abstract as well did the hypothesis
precede the data collection or not you
know or in the weird case that the data
was already collected but if you
formulated the hypothesis insulated from
information
that's in data in the library and then
you went to the library that's valid
right but just because the data
pre-existed your hypothesis if you
weren't aware of it you can still make a
prediction yeah it's not post addiction
if you are truly insulated from this uh
the evidence but anyway these are very
subtle things on which a process that
mostly is quite concrete that involves
you know beakers or transects or you
know actual physical things right it the
only reason this process works is the
underlying philosophy of science which
almost nobody who does the work has
studied right and I mean I do
guess my prediction would be that
those scientists who work
at scales that are inherently abstract
to humans or with an interface between
what they are studying and themselves
that is technological and therefore
black boxy are more likely to
misunderstand this that being a field
scientists as we have Ben and are you go
out and you are looking and working at
exactly the scale that humans interact
with
and uh the yes there's plenty of
theoretical you know underpinnings and
you're you know hoping to to see
something empirical and small that you
can then generalize so you know you're
doing hypothetical deduction doing
you're engaging in both induction and
deduction
um but there is there is stuff that you
were observing that is real and
interpretable with your own Senses at
the scales at the scale that humans can
understand it there is no inherent or at
least not always a technological
interface and uh there is no inherent
level of abstraction uh between you and
what you are observing and that's not to
say that there isn't bias there's always
bias but that does I think make it
easier
to understand why the philosophy of
science is so necessary and also just to
engage in it with integrity and go like
okay I can tell when I'm not doing this
because all the other all the other
Frills all the technology all the
abstraction of you know doing astronomy
or you know doing molecular biology if
it's about inferring
you know what the what the genes are
requires that you have put some faith in
the technology is giving me a rendition
of the truth
well there's also
Neil deGrasse Tyson is one of a tiny
number of scientists whose job is to
interface with the public
right that's it wasn't all along I mean
he's not a science Communicator by
training he was he's an astrophysicist
who became primarily a science
communicator and science communicator
and there's nothing wrong with that
right
um but what I would point out is every
scientist has some small portion of
their job that is public facing right
the scientist who is working on genomics
and then goes to a cocktail party with
people who do other things in the world
journalists lawyers doctors whatever
that person
sees themselves as having a role
speaking for science right they are in
the interface between the science
trained folks and the non-trained folks
and the point is they are presenting in
their own minds you know a simplified an
intuitive version that allows somebody
who doesn't have the training to look
into what they do for a living and the
point is actually this is a process that
gets carried away you know whereas you
and I might be the you know the skunk at
the Garden Party where somebody is
talking about the wonderful things that
are going on in University uh science
departments and we might roll our eyes
and say do you have any idea how crazy
these people are right you're not
supposed to say that and Neil deGrasse
Tyson is the far end of this Continuum
where his job is actually
to promote a sort of beautified version
of Science and what would it sound like
if a guy like Neil deGrasse Tyson
started to become alarmed you know let's
say 10 years ago about
P hacking and the replication crisis
right if he got alarmed about that
before it became public right people
would not know what to make of it if
somebody who was supposed to be
portraying science as this marvelous
process through which we come to
understand was actually so actually you
know what we're doing you know we're
lying to ourselves like come on man have
some gravitas right get so serious you
know
it is his obligation if he understood
that such a thing was taking place to do
that but I think the problem is this
sort of sense of well I have a private
understanding of how high quality the
science in my department is and then I
have an obligation uh to portray it as
better than it is in public it's the
same thing as like when when a school
you know if you are leading a tour of a
college and you are portraying the place
to prospective students Your Role is
actually to advertise the place
you shouldn't right you actually your
your obligation to the people that
you're giving the tour is actually to
give an honest assessment of what the
place is but yeah is your application to
your employer or to the people who
you're in front of right now this is
that tension exists in many many places
right that's it and so to to just finish
that off you know a guy like Neil
deGrasse Tyson sits down with Dell big
tree and in his mind his obligation is
to reveal that a guy like Dell big tree
is
right uh and in fact no it's the other
way around right
okay one more excerpt from this
important book serious Adverse Events
and uncensored history of AIDS newly
republished originally published in 2006
newly republished by Chelsea Green
publish uh Publishers I want to say
Publishers publishing house
um
by Celia fiber
in the same chapter what about Africa
she is in the rakai district of Uganda
she reports a man walked over to greet
me clasping my hand because I am white
he me and this was in
um sorry what what year was this this is
early OTs
I'm not Financial this is early OTS
she's um in Africa with a few other
people
a man walked over to greet me clasping
my hand because I am white he
immediately assumed I was there on
behalf of a western AIDS group
and that I was going to preach the
importance of condom use holding my hand
in his he said imploringly Madam let me
tell you something about us we must
procreate
the advice to use a condom every time at
Royal Uganda is clearly absurd
considering how many children they bear
and how many died in infancy
embarrassed I assured him I was not
there to preach condom use but to ask
some questions about AIDS terrible he
said shaking his head I've had two
brothers and one sister die of AIDS
already
I'm sorry I said what did they die of
slim AIDS
I mean what was the cause of death uh
well my brother for instance he had
malaria and we couldn't afford to get
him treatment so he died
so he died of untreated malaria I said
yes malaria why did you say he died of
AIDS
he Shrugged slim AIDS it's a formula for
everything here when somebody dies we
call it Slim
the who had allotted six million dollars
for aids for 1992 and 93. around the
time I was there this is earlier than I
thought sorry all other infectious
diseases combined barring tuberculosis
received only 57 thousand dollars
6 million for AIDS fifty seven thousand
dollars for all other diseases combined
in a place with a lot of tropical
diseases
Perhaps it is no wonder Farber continues
that healthcare workers there have
learned to call everything AIDS
what I'm going to write about for my sub
stack this week
which should be obvious from the couple
of
excerpts that I've read here today
and what has been pointed out by others
including for instance Robert F Kennedy
Jr in his um in his endorsement of this
book are some of the similarities
um
between
how the AIDS epidemic and crisis
progressed and how consensus
was apparently arrived at early and
often and with which there was no
dissent that would be allowed and of
course coven and it is
um
it is a remarkable set of similarities
to consider
as we look forward as we must
and think about what
will come next
yeah it's striking
what you see
is a game in which a player has become
expert
yeah you see that there is a way of
causing in this case a continent to
react
according to a narrative that is
convenient to the incentivizor
right and the idea of you know we saw
this with covet of course where the idea
was everybody who died died of covid
which made covid seem that much more
significant and therefore caused that
much more alarm which caused that much
more power to flow to those who would
cause the miscategorizing
and then we saw you know hospitals
complicit uh effectively paid to
categorize things as covid so of course
their natural
fiscal sensibility would cause them to
participate in amplifying a incorrect
understanding of how common this disease
was and how much it was responsible for
again to whom is their obligation right
right those patients are already dead
yeah who loses who loses it might seem
to the hospital administrator if we call
that and that and that a code of death
or an AIDS death if that will cause more
funds to flow and isn't our job to do
the good and honorable work of medicine
which requires money and isn't it okay
to tell this little white lie perhaps
and maybe if you compel yourself that it
isn't okay to tell yourself that little
white lie because you realize it's not a
little white lie it's a lie but it's not
a little white lie then you come to
engage in self-deception sufficiently
that you believe your own press and you
no longer understand that you are in
fact lying first Do no harm
to shareholder value
something like that
yeah it's pretty pretty upsetting in the
degree to which
um
the parallels from prior chapters that
we didn't know anything about
personally
mirrors the horrors that we've just
lived through and had to ReDiscover in
real time
indeed okay well that was depressing and
now we're leaving yes well give me
something to think about yeah
um seriously though so I'm I'm gonna
write a little bit more about this for
Natural Selections this week but um but
get this book
serious Adverse Events an uncensored
history of AIDS it will blow your mind
yeah and I I highly recommend it
um
okay
have we arrived we have arrived and
we're about to leave
we've arrived and we are about to leave
and
um you know check out check out our
patreons right now at mine as I said
before you can ask questions for the
private monthly q a that'll happen in a
couple weeks we're not going to be here
next week or we're not doing a q a this
week but we'll be back in two weeks
uh if you're looking for more content in
the meantime you can always
um go look at past episodes or Clips or
check out my writings on Natural
Selections which again if you go to
Twitter you can click through now
progress progress interesting um
fantastic
so any other announcements before
I don't think so I will undoubtedly
remember what I should have announced
early after we can close this episode
yeah that happens yep that happens okay
well until we see you next time guys be
good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]